I just wanted to make four very quick
points first the pace of change is
accelerating it is cliche but true today
will be the slowest day of your life as
we continue to have rapid technological
advancements our world is only getting
faster here's one statistic that's come
out of our research the lifespan of a
company on the S&P 500 index two
generations ago was about 50 years five
zero today it's about 16 years and the
number is decreasing 50 percent 5-0
percent of the companies on the S&P 500
index will not be on that index in ten
years second observation
this means that innovation which once
was a nicety is increasingly a necessity
this means that design that once was a
fringe discipline is essential inside
every organization every organization
has to innovate it has to do something
different that creates value and you
only can create value if you embrace
great design because if people can't use
if they can't understand if they can't
adopt the products and services you're
innovating you're going to be in trouble
third observation even more critically
the principles and approaches that good
designers follow are critical for
tomorrow's leaders what do great
designers do they have empathetic
understanding of markets they're able to
sense opportunities before data are
clear they use abductive thinking to
come up with possibilities that no one
had imagined they rapidly prototype they
test learn and experiment to address the
uncertainty that always comes along with
change these are skills and mindsets
that all leaders of tomorrow will need
because if we make decisions based only
on data only on logic only on numbers
that takes us backwards not forwards
fourth and final observation my view the
biggest opportunity and the biggest
challenge that we face as a community is
changing the mindset inside
organizations
we know that success is never a straight
line there will be the occasional
failure along the way our organizations
are not yet fully tolerant of this
psychological safety is something that
we need to see inside more organizations
in Singapore to make that superpower
really have its impact